okay now chris wallace last night was
terrible i mean truly awful
chris wallace began and i think that he
was so taken aback by trump's
very very aggressive tactics by trump's
crowd biden strategy right got him up in
the corner and then he was throwing jabs
all night long i think he was so put off
by that and so
upset and miffed frankly i think he was
so offended by trump's tactic
that he decided he was going to jump in
and become a debater there are multiple
times when trump asked biden a question
and he would jump in and say we're
moving on to the next topic and just
save joe biden
there were multiple times when joe biden
would get stuck and wallace would kind
of feed him at the next line
there were multiple questions that he
asked that were just bad questions and
those ones are more inexcusable
even because those questions were were
prepared
in advance right so donald trump very
early on
uh felt that wallace was coming after
him i thought early on
that this was not quite fair because
donald trump was in fact talking
directly over biden for about the first
15 minutes of the debate
but trump turned to wallace and he said
i guess i'm debating you and pretty much
it did turn
into that by the end of the debate trump
was not wrong about this
you in the course of these four years
have never come up with a comprehensive
plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
that
there's nothing symbolic okay the reason
you said that is because
wallace had jumped in to save biden in
one of these exchanges
okay wallace's questions last night
we're terrible so here are some examples
here was chris wallace asking donald
trump
about banning critical race theory in
the government now critical race theory
as we have discussed is a racist
ideology
critical race theory says that every
institution in the united states is
undergirded by racial supremacy
critical race theory suggests that just
by dint of your skin you're a
beneficiary of white supremacy and if
you are not anti-racist
in other words you don't want to tear
down the entire system you are racist
critical race theory training involves
people literally telling white people
in rooms sponsored by the government
that they are racist simply because they
are white
that that's what this diversity training
bullcrap from ibrahim's kennedy and
robins deangelo is
chris wallace just says something
blatantly untrue in this question he
says why are you banning racial
sensitivity training mr president
he's not banning quote unquote racial
sensitivity training he's banning
critical race theory which is a
neo-marxist
garbage ideology that should not be
taught on any college campus
any high school campus any government
agency or any contracting agency with
the federal government here is chris
wallace completely blowing the question
here
racial sensitivity training if you were
a certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to allow that to happen okay so
again the fact that wallace why why
what's so bad about racial
it's not racial sensitivity training it
isn't that the premise of the question
is wrong
okay and then of course you had wallace
asking trump to condemn white supremacy
he did not directly
ask joe biden to condemn antifa or black
lives matter right he didn't ask him
about any of that
we had chris wallace harassing trump
about global warming
i mean it was like six seven straight
questions wait why don't what do you
believe about global warming sir what do
you believe about
he gave his answer if it'd been joe
biden wallace would let it go here was
wallace harassing trump about global
warming
what do you believe about the science of
climate change
and what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
what do you believe about the science of
climate change sir do you believe
that that human pollution
gas greenhouse gas emissions contributes
to the global warming
i think if you believe in the science of
climate change
why have you rolled back the obama clean
power
plan which limited carbon emissions in
power plants why have you relaxed fuel
economy
standards that are going to create more
pollution from cars
well not really okay again that is did
wallace badger biden on anything like
that last night he asked him like twice
about packing the court and then biden
was like i'm not answering it
and then he let it go yeah i think
everything was summed up by the end of
the debate
joe biden and chris wallace were
laughing together which basically sums
up
where chris wallace ended up by the end
of the debate i think he intended to be
there at the beginning this is certainly
where he ended up
vice president answered his q his final
question
the final question is i can't remember
which of all his rantings
i'm having a little trouble myself
okay now you've just turned into a
debate participant and an ally of joe
biden
so to sum up chris wallace's performance
was terrible for moderator i mean really
really bad
two donald trump's over aggressive
performance distracted from anything
relevant that he wanted to say so he
didn't end up doing severe damage
to joe biden but and his sort of battery
on that white supremacy question
ended up damaging him maybe a little bit
i don't think it'll have any real effect
because again this has been the long
time democratic narrative that's why
that he won't condemn white supremacy
he's literally called it evil from the
roster many many times okay and joe
biden didn't perform exactly well either
so where do we end up
status quo anti we end up exactly where
we started which is
nobody gains nobody loses the problem is
for donald trump the clock is running
if he is ahead great if he's behind time
is running out
if you're going to clock joe biden and
make a difference here you need to let
him
hang himself with his own words and
trump wouldn't allow him to do that he
just kept stepping in and crowding him
you got to let him breathe enough to
fall over
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content